it's time for roses and rose they
tonight had a lot of dad jokes so let me
make one to kick things off
things got crystal clear this evening
whoa okay guys i'm lauren zima thank you
so much for being here for roses and
Rose Day as we discuss the re Lyon dykes
this season of The Bachelor so tonight
I'm gonna start things off with how
every episode is seeming to start off
this season you guys go to the beach
hall or anything I'm so excited this
seems like a great place to fall in love
wow this is amazing I know that these
are tropes from the entire series but
it's seeming like a lot this season to
me it's seeming like a lot
I need more substance any more grits
this week we are in Fort Lauderdale Fort
Lauderdale is a beautiful place to fall
in love okay and a girl comes in and
she's like honey and I'm like who is
this oh it's McHale she's back she had
to leave last week she's back great yeah
I don't know this is more my speed
actually
going at his speed a racecar driver and
then he gets a one-on-one with Chelsea
and more dad jokes Chelsea says I'm on a
dream boat but I'm also with a dream
boat oh my god Wow and I love that they
gave the women a telescope to watch
Arion Chelsea with like last week they
got binoculars to watch re in CNN this
week to get a telescope you know next
week it's gonna be that they shrink re
and whoever is on the one-on-one and all
the women get to look at them through a
microscope that would people to
exploring all the unknown and taking
chances I love that that's the thing
again I know we have our go to bachelor
phrases but I need more it's becoming
too much and to really drive home the
point of how much they're driving home
the points I want to fly Jayceon for a
dramatic reading of direct quotes from
re and Chelsea's one-on-one Jacy will be
playing the part of Ari and he's even
perfectly costumed in a cardigan because
are you remember is old he likes wear
cardigans go to bed early and I am going
to be playing the part of Chelsea today
was fun the jet skiing you're really
impressive really I had so much fun I
needed that you know today was a lot of
fun yeah it was fun a lot of fun
but great job JC playing a part of re
wonderful yay by the way someone asked
in the comments if he was single or
thought JC was hot or something both
[Music]
it's like The Bachelor answers my
prayers things do get a little more
substantial Chelsea tells this story
about splitting up with the father of
her baby and how she had nothing but
then she realized that even though she
had the least amount of things in her
life I feel like I have everything yeah
I have a little boy who was healthy
great line Chelsea I like you I like
Chelsea remember when they were kind of
mini Encino Chelsea's gonna be the
villain how the tides have turned
so Chelsea gets a rose and that's great
and I need this from Ari you know Ari as
Jacy so analytically pointed out seems
to maybe be an empath and when Jacy
analytically pointed that out I had to
google that and an empath is somebody
who feels other people's emotions almost
like really feels them and listens and
Ari is he's a good listener but I need
more talking I want Ari to have the kind
of revelations that we're here in
Chelsea hat and I get that Ari was in
love with Emily and her before and he
has been in love since we've heard that
I need more her cut to a group date and
buy more Arie is giving us more of him
being the kissing bandit more than we've
ever seen before
Ari's taking things to the next level
but not in the way I want him to Ari
licks a bowling ball
arie French kisses a bowling ball re
feels the heart of a bowling ball he
licked a bowling ball you guys serene
with it okay so it's one of those
competitive group dates where the
winning team gets to go to what re calls
the bowling after-party maybe in Arizona
things get so wild that they have
bowling after parties where are you
going are you going to the bowling
afterparty
yeah oh my god I didn't get invited to
the after-party the bowling afterparty
I love bowling after parties anyway I'm
watching the show through a little bit
of a different lens lately the lens of
the time that women are having right now
there's a moment in here where one woman
I believe it to be Jenna kind of
jokingly sings a song calling the other
team or implying to call the other team
[ __ ] and our eyes like that was
amazing and I don't know it wasn't I'm
over it let's not do that you know it's
not funny no so whichever team loses
doesn't get to go to the bowling
afterparty and one team loses and then
seemingly as punishment they get locked
in kind of a locker room bowling alley
dungeon and they're in there and then
alright comes in these like you want to
come out yes I want to come out why are
we in this locker room and Ari says that
he doesn't care about who won or lost he
wants everybody at the bowling
afterparty
yay ari is the dad we all wish we had
yes honey you can go out tonight great
this is when things start to become
crystal clear about crystal crystal who
has accused the other women of being
juvenile has what I would call quite a
teenage moment and is so upset that the
other women are allowed to go on the
party after losing that she apparently
has a freak out on a bus which they
don't have footage of where is the
footage of that come on you guys you
have cameras everywhere and you weren't
filming what's happening on that bus
please install some GoPros next time and
when they get back to the hotel they're
staying at she takes her mic off
she is boycotting the group date all my
stuff is packed right now in my bedroom
I'm not sure if this has ever happened
in the history of the franchise before
please let me know in the comments if it
has boycotting the dates she says that
Ari is a liar that she can't trust him
anymore because he lied about who got to
go back on the date why he just came up
with a new plan I think you should stay
up here tonight I'm gonna go down and
hang with him and then he went
downstairs and told the other women
she's gonna stay up there Crystal's
gonna stay in her room tonight she has a
timeout in her room and she does not get
dinner yeah we can relax a little bit
and sort of shake that off you know
yikes I think to me that implied a
little bit that he's starting to get
crystal you know he's like we can relax
without her cuz I know how stressful
she's been for you guys I didn't want to
play a game with you let's do it um 21
question okay I don't know this game do
you guys know this game
I know 20 questions where it's like we
got to figure out you know who who we're
both talking about but apparently 21
questions is we just got to figure each
other out because it's seemingly a game
where they just alternate asking each
other questions and the questions aren't
what I would call Pulitzer Prize winning
sit-down type of questions what's your
favorite color
if you can answer that all right what's
your favorite color
how do you like your eggs berry runaway
bride the how do you like your eggs
thing you were so lost you even know
what kind of eggs you like how do you
like your coffee Lauren B says with
coconut milk twitch Ari's like whoa okay
whoa coconut milk
I don't know I'm worried I'm gonna fall
for you and then you're gonna want
coconut milk in your coffee and in
Arizona we bowl we don't have Coke okay
so I'm afraid that I am gonna fall for
you and you're gonna chase someone else
I think my biggest fear Ari and Lauren
BIA this conversation where as part of
the questions they asked what other
person's biggest fear was and it seems
very obvious you know Lauren B says I'm
afraid you're gonna pick someone else
and then Ari says my biggest fear is off
to choose someone who is right for me
that's heard and those fears seem so
obvious and it makes me wonder if they
put this conversation in as a little bit
of foreshadowing so Lauren B gets the
rose and then Tia and Arie go on a
one-on-one date in a swamp and this was
fun I like Tia and I like Gerald they're
at some guy Gerald's house we don't know
why where does the bachelor find these
people how and where did they discover
and cast Gerald Yelp reviews I don't
know but Gerald quote invented deep
fried corn-on-the-cob
which is my own invention oh yeah deep
fried corn-on-the-cob
and i am here for that
you are that's quite a milestone on the
show an Ari's response is again a little
dad like he's like ha oh thank you
thanks honey you do your homework okay
every time we hang out I feel more
myself when I'm around her been with any
other women that's interesting to me
that's a big statement from Mari which I
liked hearing that from him
and I think that means T is gonna go far
vo somebody you can be yourself with it
deep deep fried corn-on-the-cob with
mm-hmm Oh ice you guys aren't gonna like
this sound sorry about it I think
tonight is the most nervous I've been
then it's rose ceremony night and
crystal does something so unexpected you
know it made me really I enjoy watching
her because she's full of surprises
she you know keeps saying she feels
attacked by the other women and so she
says to them I would love to chat with
you about it privately this is funny to
me because so much of the bachelor is
about getting time with with the lead
and crystals like auditioning to be the
Bachelorette she's like here's what it'd
be like to get time with me everybody
can have their time line up and we'll
have some in-depth discussions so first
up is Kendall and crystals like you were
reacting to my reaction and like you're
getting mad at me for being emotional or
something I was really getting lost
there and then Becca comes in with that
wisdom that you know people criticize
her for being 22 but Becca just laid it
out there and she just goes why are you
still here
why are you still here no really I'm
asking you are you sniper I don't think
we ever got crystals response but she
did throw glitter I don't know what that
was you stood there and said that it was
glitter why why glitter so crystalline
re-meet up and shot at rose ceremony
night and re is being very strong with
crystal he's saying he did not approve
of her behavior that her reactions did
not seem warranted that's why I like
having trusting someone your word like I
don't want a marriage for me Trust is
important to everyone I don't know
anyone who's like lie to me date me and
lie to me I love it it's so healthy and
great I want to be with someone who's a
liar nobody says that everybody wants
trust crystal that's not unique to you
but crystal thinks things are unique to
her I think and she she victimizes
herself a lot this is our first fight
and it's like telling us see like it
could be the last fight I started to
feel the this environment is not healthy
for crystal you know I think that maybe
crystal needs to be in a different place
physically and mentally crystal wakes up
the stress so that doesn't happen
crystal sticks around she gets a rose
and some other women go home and I don't
remember their names but they seem
lovely oh thank you all so much for
being here I have to say I don't think
tonight's shed any additional light on
who our frontrunner will be maybe Tia
scooch it up a little bit further to the
front of the pack because Ari seems to
feel himself with her but overall a good
episode to watch
I miss Lake Tahoe like Tahoe felt so
fantastical but next week Paris Bonjour
and these are French kisses don't like a
bowling ball
au revoir thank you all again please
leave your comments in the comment
section and make sure to keep watching
roses and Rosie Rosie is a French wine
bang
ah what was the theme of tonight dad
jokes things becoming crystal-clear ari
is a dreamboat but we need his ship to
sail into deeper waters Wow
[Music]
where's Gerald when you need him to
finish off this evening some deep fried
corn-on-the-cob something to chew on you
know